el médico se la entregó a sus padres
y, basándose en los genitales del bebé, dijo:
"Es un varón".
Siempre supo que no era varón.
Los años fueron pasando, y lo que ella iba sintiendo
y reteniendo en su interior crecía cada vez más,
y sabía que debía decírselo a su familia.
Cuando lo hizo, no fue tan fácil.
Los padres le dijeron: "De ninguna manera, no eres una chica.
No es así como te hemos criado. No entendemos qué te pasa.
Márchate".
Y Anne terminó en la calle, deambulando por distintos refugios para indigentes.
Fue allí donde se inició en el consumo de drogas y alcohol
para mitigar el dolor que sentía por dentro.
Me contó de su deambular por hospitales y centros de rehabilitación
para recuperarse.
Y cuando lo lograba, los profesionales sanitarios y los médicos
no se dirigían a ella usando su nombre o palabras en femenino.
Esto era muy doloroso para ella.
Durante mi formación como terapeuta,
no me enseñaron a trabajar con pacientes transgénero.
Nunca imaginé que trabajaría con pacientes de este tipo.
Pero cuando empecé a trabajar con Anne y otros pacientes como ella,
mi misión empezó a evolucionar,
y esa misión era lograr que la comunidad transgénero
pudiera recibir la atención médica que necesita.
Al ahondar en el tema, supe que ese miedo tan real
a la violencia, la discriminación y la falta de aceptación
obligaba a estos pacientes a volcarse al alcohol y a las drogas.
También escuché historias terribles
de pacientes que buscaban atención médica,
del trato que recibían,
y cuánto se ignoraban sus necesidades de salud.
Les contaré ahora la historia de Leah.
Tuve el placer de conocerla hace unos años.
Es mujer y tiene su esposa e hijos.
Leah también fue considerada varón desde el nacimiento
y desde niña supo que no era varón,
sino una mujer.
Ocultó este sentimiento de sí misma y de quienes la rodeaban,
especialmente de su esposa.
Y a los 50 años, ya no lo pudo soportar.
Se dijo: "No puedo seguir viviendo así.
Tengo que sincerarme".
Tenía terror de contárselo a su esposa.
¿Y si su esposa le decía:
"Es inaceptable. Quiero el divorcio. Márchate"?
Para su sorpresa, su esposa lo aceptó.
Dijo: "Te amo, no importa quién eres.
Quiero ayudarte como pueda".
Entonces lo hablaron,
y Leah decidió acudir al médico para hacer la transición,
y estaba dispuesta a recibir una terapia de reemplazo hormonal,
o TRH.
Concertó una cita con el médico.
Acudió a la consulta con antelación,
completó los formularios,
puso su nombre correctamente y esperó pacientemente.
Pasado un tiempo, una enfermera la llamó al consultorio.
Cuando entró, respiró profundamente,
y el médico y la enfermera entraron.
Ella le extendió la mano al médico y le dijo: "Hola, soy Leah".
El médico la miró, no le estrechó la mano y dijo:
"¿Por qué está aquí?"
Leah respiró profundo nuevamente y respondió:
"Soy una mujer transgénero.
Lo sentí así toda mi vida, y se lo oculté a todos,
pero ya no puedo más.
Mi esposa me apoya, y económicamente puedo hacerlo.
Quiero hacer estos cambios.
Le pido que evalúe la posibilidad de darme una TRH".
El médico le dijo: "Hoy no es posible.
Debe hacerse un análisis de VIH".
Leah no lo podía creer.
Estaba furiosa,
enojada, decepcionada.
Si su médico la trataba de esa manera, ¿qué podría esperar de los demás?
Primero, no le estrechó la mano,
y segundo, cuando supo que Leah era transgénero,
solo le recomendó una prueba de VIH y dio por terminada la consulta.
No le hizo ninguna otra pregunta.
Entiendo muy bien la historia de Leah,
porque en los años que llevo trabajando con la comunidad,
todos los días escucho mitos que no son verdad.
Por ejemplo:
las personas transgénero quieren hacer la transición con fármacos o cirugía;
las personas transgénero tienen una enfermedad mental, un trastorno;
y estas personas, en realidad, no son ni hombre ni mujer.
Todos son mitos, todas son ideas falsas.
A medida que esta comunidad se expande y va envejeciendo,
es fundamental que se capacite a todos los profesionales de la salud
para atender sus necesidades de salud.
En el año 2015, se realizó una encuesta
según la cual el 72 % de los profesionales de la salud
manifestaron no contar con información adecuada
sobre las necesidades médicas de la comunidad LGBT.
Hay una brecha enorme en la educación y la capacitación.
Hoy quiero mostrarles
una nueva manera de pensar sobre tres grupos de personas:
los médicos, la comunidad transgénero y el resto de nosotros.
Pero antes, quiero repasar algunas definiciones
para que puedan terminar de entender la idea de la identidad de género.
Tomen lápiz y papel, y anoten.
Comencemos por el concepto del sistema binario.
Esto significa que antes siempre pensábamos
que había solo dos géneros: hombre y mujer.
Binario, ¿se entiende?
Pero ahora sabemos que ese concepto no es correcto.
La identidad de género es un espectro
con la masculinidad a un extremo
y la femineidad en el otro.
Este espectro de identidades
incluye categorías como la no conformidad con el género,
la conformidad con el género,
el género no binario,
de dos espíritus, de tres espíritus,
y también intersexuales.
El término "transgénero" es genérico
e incluye todas estas identidades distintas.
Pero en esta charla, pensemos en una persona transgénero
como aquella cuyo sexo de nacimiento no coincide
con lo que la persona siente, con lo que la identifica.
Esto es muy distinto del sexo biológico.
La identidad de género es cómo la persona se percibe.
Pensémoslo como lo que hay entre las orejas:
la percepción de uno mismo, de quienes somos.
Es muy distinto al sexo biológico.
Las hormonas, los genitales, los cromosomas...
eso está entre la piernas.
Ahora bien, me dirán: "Doctora, nunca tuve dudas de quién soy.
Sé que soy hombre, o sé que soy mujer".
Está claro. Cada uno sabe quién es.
Así es como se sienten muchas personas transgénero.
También saben quiénes son,
con la misma convicción.
Es importante saber que hay muchos tipos de identidades,
y yo me identifico como mujer cisgénero.
Para los que quieren saber cómo se escribe la palabra,
"cis" se escribe C - I - S.
Significa "de este lado" en latín.
Cuando yo nací,
el médico me alzó y les dijo a mis padres:
"Es una niña".
Lo dijo basándose en mis genitales.
Si bien me crié en una pequeña granja en Georgia,
y no era demasiado femenina,
nunca dudé de que era mujer.
Siempre supe que lo era,
independientemente de mi conducta en la infancia.
Ahora bien, esto es muy distinto a ser una persona transgénero.
El término "trans" significa "del otro lado de" en latín.
Por eso decimos "línea aérea transcontinental",
a través de, del otro lado de.
Se refiere entonces a quien se le asigna un sexo al nacer,
pero esa persona se identifica con el otro lado del espectro.
Un hombre transgénero es alguien a quien se le asignó el sexo femenino al nacer,
pero se identifica, se siente y vive su vida como varón.
Y lo opuesto es, como dije antes,
una mujer transgénero que nace con sexo masculino
pero vive y se identifica como mujer.
Es importante subrayar
que no todos lo que tienen una identidad no binaria
se identifican con el término "transgénero".
Para que no se confundan, voy a aclarar lo que es la identidad sexual,
u orientación sexual.
Es simplemente la persona que nos atrae,
física, emocional, sexual, espiritualmente.
No es igual que la identidad de género.
Para resumir, entonces, antes de continuar:
la identidad de género está entre las orejas;
el sexo biológico, entre las piernas;
y la identidad sexual... bueno, a veces usamos el corazón,
pero está aquí.
Tres espectros muy distintos de identidad.
Ahora bien, los estudiantes de medicina dedican unas cinco horas
al estudio de las necesidades médicas de la comunidad LGBT
cuando están en la universidad,
a pesar de que sabemos que esta comunidad tiene riesgos de salud
y necesidades muy particulares.
Se estima que hay unos 10 millones de adultos en EE. UU.
que se identifican como LGBT.
La mayoría de los médicos que trabajan con pacientes transgénero
aprenden sobre la marcha.
Esto significa que deben ir improvisando en el camino,
o el paciente termina enseñándole al médico cómo debe tratarlos.
Muchos médicos se sienten incómodos al preguntar sobre la identidad de género.
A algunos les parece que no tiene importancia en el marco del tratamiento
y otros simplemente no quieren decir algo inapropiado.
Cuando los médicos dicen algo fuera de lugar o algo negativo,
no son necesariamente mal intencionados.
Probablemente nunca les enseñaron a tratar a este tipo de personas.
Pero esto ya no es aceptable.
¿Qué ocurre entonces con un hombre transgénero?
Recordemos, una persona que nace con sexo femenino
pero vive como hombre.
¿Qué ocurre cuando un hombre transgénero
acude a hacerse un chequeo ginecológico de rutina?
La manera en que ese médico trate al paciente
condicionará el clima de la consulta.
Si ese médico trata a ese hombre usando las palabras en masculino,
estará mostrando respeto y dándole dignidad,
y es muy probable que también lo haga el resto del personal.
Pues bien, esta es mi opinión sobre la comunidad médica,
y ahora voy a referirme a la comunidad transgénero.
Les hablaré del miedo,
pero todos sabemos quién realmente tiene miedo:
la comunidad transgénero.
Al principio les hablé de Anne
y de su preocupación por iniciar un tratamiento
y no ser respetada como la mujer que siente ser.
Luego hablé de Leah, que temía la reacción del médico,
y en el momento en que él no le estrechó la mano
y le pidió que se hiciera un análisis de VIH, sus temores se confirmaron.
La comunidad transgénero debe ser empoderada
para hablar de sus necesidades médicas.
Se acabó la época en que se quedaban callados cuando recibían un tratamiento.
Si ellos no comunican sus necesidades médicas,
nadie lo hará por ellos.
Y ¿qué pasa con el resto de nosotros?
Quizá muchos de ustedes, la semana o el mes que viene,
acudan a una consulta médica.
Imaginemos que tienen la consulta
y, al finalizar, se sienten peor que antes de la visita.
Bien podrían sentir
que el médico ignoró sus necesidades, incluso que los juzgó equivocadamente.
Así es como se sienten muchos de los 1,4 millones de adultos transgénero
aquí en EE. UU.
si tienen la suerte de ir a una consulta.
Ahora bien, podrían preguntarse: "¿Por qué debería importarme esto?
No soy transgénero, no conozco a nadie que lo sea.
¿Qué más da?".
Piénsenlo de este modo.
Una persona transgénero es humana,
como Uds. y como yo.
Tienen derecho a atención médica calificada,
Les voy a pedir ahora que levanten la mano
quienes conozcan o hayan conocido a una persona transgénero,
de género no conforme, sin género, intersexual, de dos o tres espíritus.
Gracias. Muy bien.
Quienes no levantaron la mano,
tendrán en el futuro cercano
la oportunidad de conocer
a alguien que esté en una de estas categorias, se los aseguro.
Esta comunidad está en expansión.
Y no es porque esté de moda o sea una nueva tendencia,
Simplemente porque es más seguro darse a conocer.
Hay más conciencia, hay más visibilidad.
Hay más seguridad, y por eso muchos hablan de su verdadera identidad
como nunca se había hecho en el pasado.
Por eso, es importante que el sistema de atención sanitaria se comprometa
a capacitar a los médicos y profesionales de la salud
para tratar a estos pacientes con el respeto y la dignidad
que esperamos para nosotros mismos.
Recuerdo cuando en la clase de literatura en la escuela,
uno de mis profesores favoritos, el Sr. McClain,
compartió una cita de Heráclito que recuerdo hasta el día de hoy.
Seguramente la conocen:
"Lo único constante es el cambio".
Un frase conocida, ¿verdad?
Cada uno de nosotros debe enfrentar cambios en la vida,
y esto a veces nos obliga a tomar decisiones,
algunas difíciles.
¿Nos estancaremos en el miedo
y dejaremos de crecer?
0 ¿enfrentaremos los miedos con valentía,
evolucionaremos y aprovecharemos la oportunidad para crecer?
Todos debemos enfrentar cosas nuevas.
¿Qué harían Uds.?
¿Se quedarán atrapados en el temor,
o crecerán?
Los invito a cada uno, a los médicos, a la comunidad transgénero,
a Uds. y a mí,
a que juntos enfrentemos los miedos
en este mundo nuevo.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)